et le plus beau c'est qu'il se recorche
je l'ai battu avec les chaussures de mon
remplaçant parce que mes chaussures ont
rendu l'âme donc j'ai marqué 13 buts
avec ces chaussures et à la fin de la
compétition je l'ai rendu
les chaussures et je sais pas ce que
sont devenues elles ont dû terminer dans
une poubelle
[Musique]
fontaine avant le championnat du monde
vous étiez un très bon joueur puisque
vous étiez ensemble ou inter droit à
Reims mais au moment du Championnat du
Monde vous avez ce que l'on dit éclaté
vous êtes devenu un joueur de tout
premier ordre sur le plan mondial
puisque vous avez été les meilleurs
marqueurs de but de la Coupe du Monde
pouvez-vous me dire quel a été la raison
de cette transformation ben il y a cela
plusieurs raisons c'est à dire que la
première c'est que je n'avais jamais
évolué dans une équipe de France qui
tourne et malgré mes qualités de buteur
que j'avais en championnat national je
pouvais pas les confirmer en match
international du fait que l'équipe de
France se cherchait à ce moment-là nous
allons passer un mois ensemble avant de
commencer championnat du monde et que il
est régné une atmosphère de club c'est à
dire que je ne me suis pas senti dépaysé
du tout et
évidemment quand un joueur a le moral il
fait des choses extraordinaires
débuter à Marrakech
mon père voulait pas que je joue au foot
il me laissait faire du basket à peu
près tous les sports sauf le foot parce
qu'il avait peur que je me casse une
jambe comme si ça pouvait arriver
[Musique]
à 70 ans c'est un jeune retraité qui
nous reçoit chez lui dans sa maison
toulousaine remplie de souvenirs de la
tapisserie à l'assiette nominative en
passant par la Légion d'Honneur juste on
a reçu des récompenses pour un exploit
mondial encore inégalé 13 buts marqués
en une seule coupe du monde celui dont
tout le monde se souvient c'est le
premier but
légalisation contre le Brésil parce que
le Brésil avait joué 4 matchs sans
prendre un but il menait à zéro et donc
on a égalisé donc
quand on projette des images une seule
image d'un coup du monde on projette ce
but là qui était d'ailleurs
un très joli but mais bon
mais en fait les 13 étaient beaux
1958 la date est inoubliable et les
anecdotes aussi
matchs donc il va falloir laver parce
que ils avaient pas prévu qu'on irait si
loin quoi si vous dire si j'étais
optimiste et le plus beau c'est qu'il se
recorche les battu avec les chaussures
de mon remplaçant parce que mes
chaussures ont rendu l'âme donc j'ai
marqué 13 buts avec ces chaussures et à
la fin de la compétition je l'ai rendu
les chaussures et je sais pas ce
qu'elles sont devenues elles ont dû
terminer dans une poubelle
[Musique]